[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the secrets easter eggs and some
other references you might have missed
while watching the newly released
minions the rise of gru if you haven't
watched the movie yet press pause watch
it and then come back because we're
going to discuss some heavy spoilers if
you liked the video be sure to leave us
a like and subscribe to the channel to
not miss out on any future content
regarding your favorite animation movies
without further ado let's get started
in the film's opening sequence we see a
minion on a ball hitting straight into
the illumination title and obstructing
it this scene is an homage to miley
cyrus's wrecking ball the minion surely
comes in like a wrecking ball
gru fantasizes about entering the
vicious 6 an avenger-style corporation
of baddies formed by wild knuckles while
gru is tied directly to a clock tower by
the vicious 6 he starts yelling out to
his dedicated minions and appears to say
minions assemble an explicit resemblance
to the major motion picture avengers
endgame when all the avengers are facing
off against the adversary thanos and
captain america says the iconic line
avengers assemble
in one incident the minions are
converted into different animals
including stewart who is transmogrified
into a chicken this is an apparent
reference to one of the franchise's
earlier iterations particularly
despicable me 2 in which groom must try
and deal with polo loco polo loco is
eduardo salsa store guard dog but he is
absolutely a chicken and not really a
dog
we witness a blue van with blossoms
gliding over the protagonist's faces
while gru and his minions are fighting a
war with the vicious six do the blossoms
inform you of anything considerable from
the 1970s if you look really closely it
looks an awful lot like the legendary
scooby-doo mystery machine
when grundy's minions take a trip to the
movie theater he lets loose a stink bomb
on the entire audience does this make
you think of something because this was
not the first time gru used a stink
explosive this is a direct reference to
the first despicable me film where dr
nefario presents gru with his fart gun
which he genuinely believes grew
demanded i said dart gun not fart gun
gru attempted to
the vicious 6 supervillain group sounds
very familiar this is because it
parallels another heinous gang of marvel
studios super villains known as the
sinister six the sinister six or
collective of super villains who show up
in marvel studios american comics pretty
much exclusively though starring
spider-man driven by dr octopus the team
swiftly followed the very initial cameos
of many of spider-man's most everlasting
participants vulture sandman electro
mysterio and craven the hunter while dr
octopus has typically stated its
commander the sinister six's structure
has changed quite a bit
speaking of the vicious six we
acknowledge that one of the super
villains appeared to fit perfectly in
with all the others from stanley
kubrick's a clockwork orange because of
the robotic claw bicep jean claude is
the name of this super villain and is
performed by belgian actor jean-claude
himself if only he had somehow done a
few splits in this film as well
in the scene where gru is struggling to
break into a safety deposit box things
do not appear to be running well for him
if you pay very close attention you
might start noticing that you've seen
gru's new outfit before yes it really
does look like russell's costume from
pixar's up when he begins moving high in
the clouds perhaps all grew needs is a
couple of balloons to open the vault
when group goes to the vicious six
headquarters to try and join their super
villain alliance he meets several other
villains who are also eagerly waiting to
join the squad and are standing in line
in the waiting area one of them is
reading a magazine if you pay attention
if you look really closely the magazine
is a 1961 version of mad magazine with a
cover image featuring richard nixon
stewart immediately jumps into the bed
from above when gru settles down between
everyone's absolute favorite minions bob
and steve if you watch carefully you
will notice that he is dolled up in a
red smoking dress jacket this is more of
an adult reference and definitely seems
to be the wardrobe staple worn by hugh
hefner the originator of playboy in the
same scene an open vault can be seen on
gru's bedside table making the audience
wonder what it holds
when gruner's minions enter the cinema
we recognize a movie poster for the film
jaws in the back steven spielberg
directed jaws which was also produced by
universal studios
an alarm clock can be seen on gru's
bedside table in a prior scene where he
is in bed with his faithful minions it
is not the sort of alarm clock you would
assume a young kid to have this is
because it is not it is a ticking time
bomb
marlena gru's mother was never the type
of mother who fully deserved mothering
accolades because we saw her victimize
and grew and questioning his abilities
from the start things are no different
with her and the rise of gru as we see a
very uncautious mother who has never
looked down for her son even though we
see her for a very short instant the
film takes it to a whole other level by
portraying her as a free-spirited
hipster who exercises meditation with
random guys
we first encountered gru in despicable
me back in 2010 when he seems to be
utilizing a freeze ray on unknown
strangers in a coffee shop with no shame
or guilt this shows how he hates waiting
in lines this must be one of his
favorite activities as we see him
employing a cheese ray and paralyzing
people in the very same way in rise of
gru
in addition to everything else in gru's
bedroom that demonstrates his desire to
become a baddie in the long term there
is an original poster on the wall to the
right of his bed yes it is a strong old
poster if you watch hard strongholds is
a prominent member of the vicious six a
rogue-ish group that plays a big role in
the movie
while the minions endeavor to fly an
aircraft into the sky this strange
journey is full of entertaining moments
one of the minions whacks open the pilot
door finally revealing himself to be
rolled up in pink toilet paper this is a
specific parallel to a previous film in
the despicable me series specifically
despicable me 3 in which minions travel
to france and outperforms a dance on a
stage using pink toilet tissue
we see certain recognizable furniture
pieces in the background when young gru
is talking to the representatives of the
vicious six particularly wild knuckles
these couches resemble crocodiles and
are best suited for super villains they
are also a throwback to the despicable
me series where comparable couches can
be found in gru's household
when gru is called up before the vicious
6 for an appointment to fill the vacant
spot in the violent criminal league he
shows up at criminal records a massive
and super awesome record store this is a
highly amusing and quite crazy name for
a store but it has a tricky double
meaning consider for a moment that
criminal records also correspond to what
is commonly known as a police record
which is the official record kept by the
police regarding a person's criminal
history what a good metaphor for the
headquarters of the most heinous
criminals
we all know how much gru adores gadgets
and in this film we see gru and his
mastermind pal dr nefario meet for the
first time when he goes to meet dr
nefario they instantaneously click and
become spontaneous coalition partners
nefario basically gives gru one of his
scientific breakthroughs a weapon that
shoots a sticky hand called smart goo
and tells him that if you ever get
famous remember who gave you your first
gadget this is an intriguing way to
connect the two of them
kevin stewart and bob are all time
favorite minions this film clearly shows
that they have always been like this
from the early stages as they are always
seen pioneering missions and not
allowing other minions to sparkle too
much however in this movie we meet a
whole other minion named otto who is
similarly awkward and pertinent he has
his own storyline and a lot of
potentials he speaks too much makes
significant errors and jeopardizes gru's
plan to steal the zodiac stone which is
a very magical stone that has the power
to turn people into animals
bob stewart and mike are seen seeking
gru while trying to escape wild knuckles
hitman while walking up and down a
comical version of san francisco's roads
this is where they meet master cho in
chinatown master cho is a kung fu expert
that saves them and then teaches them
kung fu in a series of classical and
advanced scenes filled with specific
references to kill bill volume 1.
that's it for today have you noticed
some of these secrets already did we
leave out another secret or easter egg
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to leave us a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe for more
content on the biggest upcoming
blockbusters until next time
[Music]